sie kommen zum heiraten video auf meiner
neuen wohnung wir machen heute eine
ruptur weil ich den ganzen tag streiten
wieder und dann mit aufnehmen können wir
die räume die kinder wohl haben wir
beginnen direkt wie beginnen direkt mit
der küche die küche hat einzig mögliche
eingerichtete jahren waren sie noch
entweder abgeklebt zu machen und
gartenfreunde ich eigentlich richtige am
sonntag einzige und kühlschrank becker
nein also das ist ja meine erste wohnung
andere branchen
ich bin mega der wohnung auch das wir
bekommen haben
falls beim 40 leute bei dem bis zum
termin zu bekommen
der immobilienmakler arbeitet dann
könnte schon so überlegen wie kann es
sein weil ich denke mal ich mache eine
zeitung nur wenn rw wenn ich ein
[Musik]
bisschen
gearbeitet wird und man mit die beide
york lebt aber regen und nur ich gehen
für die fast vorbei also ein kleines
aber natürlich meine erste wohnung dass
wenn wir mehr
immer höher auf vorgestellt der
torrichter führen bevor die hier
reingehen wenn die linke an die wand
schreiben wir gerade was gemalt es
bringe ich euch jetzt erstmal ein
wir werden weiter ein youtube an die
wand malen und ihr durch entscheiden wir
besser gemalt hat und würden die
kommentare schreiben
[Musik]
grund wir machen wie sollte es anders
sein café an die wand und beginnt in 54
323 tore
meine zukünftigen video waren
[Musik]
ok also wie gesagt hier im wohnbereich
parkett war so da unten
das wird eine schöne große chance'
planwerten mitbürger ich liebe dich auf
den boden wettmachen
schon ab morgen wieder gleich gefallen
es wird ziemlich kurz mit typisch
arbeiterkammern video leider und leider
abonniert um das leid